candy man candy man selon la légende
urbaine
si tu dis souvent saint-florent de
regardant dans un miroir
il apparaît derrière toi il te tue bon
ben toujours vivante
allez venez trina attaque à stella porte
[Musique]
je me sens vraiment en phase avec ce
quartier cabrini green
c'était une cité je viens d'emménager
juste à l'angle l'ancienne usine de
confiserie tu es artiste tu cherches
candy man c'est le monstre qui fait
partie de notre quartier pourquoi cette
attire
je veux raconter cette histoire tout sur
candy man le miroir vous invite à
l'invoquer rigide itsuno qui vous l'osez
candy man candyman candyman candy man
arrête toi la cantine
j'aurais pas dû faire ça
tu les ramener candy man n'existe pas
c'est pas ce qui m'arrive
il avait un projet pour toi ils
voulaient embarquer dans une de ces
horribles histoires faut croire qu'il a
su retrouver
la douce odeur du sang
à ma victime